it is thanksgiving and i couldn't think
of anyone better to talk to on
thanksgiving than the great dave ramsey
he's helped so many people who are in
financial straights make their lives
better and in doing so has taught so
many americans to be grateful for the
free system in which we live he has a
brand new book out it's called baby
steps millionaires dave thanks so much
for joining the show it's great to see
you well it's an honor to be back with
you my friend so let's talk a little bit
about thanksgiving generally because you
know again i think that one of the
things americans don't appreciate enough
i mean first of all we don't appreciate
everything enough but i think one of the
things that we don't appreciate enough
is that
we live in a system where if you make
responsible decisions you will see the
benefit of those decisions and that
really has been your entire message
throughout your entire career well it
has been and it's upsetting to the uh
wealthy quality crowd the socialism uh
drum that's being beat right now in
america but um all along even when i was
young and now that i'm old it's still
true
the greatest system that the world has
ever known
for the little man to get ahead is the
current state of america today
the little man has a better chance i've
been a millionaire twice that's how i'm
so dumb i had to do it two times you
know and so the you got two shots i mean
you got ultimate shots at it and so but
it's all about me taking responsibility
and me making decisions and me
understanding that you're going to reap
what you sow so if you put corn seed in
the ground don't be shocked that corn
grows
so let's talk for a second about how you
define millionaire in this book because
it's kind of interesting right there are
a bunch of different ways in the united
states we define millionaire you do it
in terms of income you could
theoretically do it in terms of wealth
how do you define millionaire in this
book well there's technically only one
real definition uh there's definitions
that have agendas like
for instance you hear politicians say
that a millionaire is someone who makes
a million dollars a year that is not the
definition there's an accounting finance
definition for millionaire it's fairly
simple assets minus liabilities what you
own
minus what you owe
when that equals greater than a million
dollars you are by definition of a you
are by definition a millionaire it's not
a moral construct it's not a decision of
if that's enough or not enough or too
much it's not any of those things it's a
math equation what you own minus what
you owe and how many americans actually
are millionaires because one of the
things that we see politicians play with
is this idea that you can never get
ahead no one's a millionaire but one of
the things that we see is people
accruing generational wealth over the
course of their lives not by being elon
musk but by simply working hard and
making smart decisions with with their
money my parents are examples of this my
parents were never wealthy when i was
growing up we grew up until i was 11 in
a two-bedroom house there were four kids
in the house one bathroom was like 1100
square feet and then they gradually
traded up to a slightly bigger house
where we had our own bedrooms and and
now they are millionaires by the stats
because they're in their 60s and they
saved money for their entire life and
didn't make dumb decisions with money
exactly that's exactly what occurs
there's somewhere around 13 million
millionaires in america today
we completed a couple of years ago at
ramsey in our research department an
airtight piece of research the largest
study of millionaires ever done over 10
164 of them were surveyed and we did
in-depth discussions with them to find
out exactly who they are
demographically who they are you know
where did their money come from what are
their uh careers all those kinds of
things here's what's interesting we have
proven now statistically again with the
largest study ever done of millionaires
that 89
of the millionaires in north america
today did not become millionaires
because of inheritance as a matter of
fact 79
received absolutely zero inheritance
five percent received a very small
inheritance five thousand dollars from
the grandmother or something like that
not enough to make them a millionaire
and another five percent received
substantial money after they were
already
millionaires like a friend of mine you
know he's got a 1.2 million dollar net
worth his parents passed away after he
was already a millionaire left him 250
000 more so now he's 1.45 and i think
that people failed to understand that
because when you see again politicians
talk about this stuff they seem to
suggest that everybody who's wealthy in
the united states inherited their wealth
and that the middle class has completely
disappeared and that what they're
failing to recognize is that over the
course of the last 40 years the reason
that the middle class has quote unquote
disappeared is because most of the
people who are middle class became upper
middle class are wealthy well and the
definition of middle class has
completely changed in 1960 middle class
was an 1100 square foot brick home with
1.2 cars in the driveway today middle
class is 2 800 square foot two-story
with with 2.3 cars in the driveway
meaning they've got on average so we
define middle class by what in 1960 we
would have called at least upper middle
class maybe lower upper class and so
we've changed our standards of living so
high across the board america that we
have the richest poor people in the
world so let's talk about the current
state of america's economy because we've
seen inflation that has been spiraling
this year real wages have dropped
compared to inflation honestly i'm
shocked that anybody was surprised by
the inflation given the fact that we
blew seven trillion dollars into the
american economy last year and then
earlier in the year we tossed another
two trillion dollars at the economy and
then joe biden just tossed another 1.2
trillion dollars of the economy and he's
currently seeking to toss another five
trillion dollars at the economy if you
blow this much money into the economy
you shouldn't really be surprised that
fewer people are working and inflation
is is going up but what do you think are
the the systemic risks to the economy do
you think inflation comes back under
control or do you think that this is
going to be embedded in the future of
america's economy i'm hopeful it comes
under control
for multiple reasons
i'm with you i think the reason part of
the reason for the inflation is this
ridiculous government policy of just
printing money like there's no tomorrow
and throwing it at everything and paying
people to not work but the other thing
that's caused this particular piece of
inflation it's very unusual and i didn't
see it coming but i looking back on it i
kind of feel like i should have seen it
coming anytime there's an earthquake at
sea
following that
there's a tsunami if it's a major
earthquake at sea so you'll get a
10-story wave
that hits the the shore days later or
hours or whatever later after the
earthquake at sea the earthquake at sea
was the pandemic we shut the economy
completely down we shut down all
factories we shut down our supply chain
we shut down all production
and most consumption but not all of it
and and then we put people back to work
sort of but we paid them to not work so
we disrupted the supply chain we
disrupted the supply demand of goods and
services and we disrupted the labor
markets with this ridiculous policy
coming out of washington continuing to
pay people not to work and so we've had
this perfect storm that has resulted in
unbelievable spikes in almost every
category the only category that's not
caused by this is oil and that's caused
by shutting off pipelines and ridiculous
policy again out of uh shutting down
supply it's a supply demand curve
anytime there's a shortage you see a
jump in price shortage of toilet paper
jump in price shortage of gasoline jump
in price shortage of labor jump in price
anytime that that's a supply demand
curve from the seventh grade so my hope
is
that two things will occur over the next
five to ten years to do away with this
one is after the tsunami the waves go
out and we repair and get back to a
fairly normal capitalistic society again
and my hope is is that we change
administrations and quit spending money
like a drunken sailor do you think that
there is something to the theory that
many americans over the past year and a
half have been
so comfortable with being dependent on
government that a lot of people just
aren't going back into the workforce
this is one of my concerns that you see
the labor force participation rate in
western civilization dropping radically
nearly across the board i mean right now
our labor force participation rate is
like 61 so meaning all working age
adults only 61 percent of them are
actually working among younger people
it's much lower than that a huge
percentage of them are not working and i
just wonder if so many people are just
getting addicted to the government
health they're not going to go back into
the workforce at all right and so we
have to do away with the source of their
addiction uh i mean we have to cut the
government help is out of control
because we're helping people that don't
need help
uh meaning that we're paying people to
not work that are able-bodied and could
get work and there's plenty of work out
there to do right now
tremendous labor shortages in several
industries right now and so uh you try
running a restaurant right now oh my
gosh it's awful try getting a you know
hotel beds made
ridiculously hard
so people in the service industries uh
that were the first ones that got hurt
the most uh with the pandemic quarantine
and the shutdowns
it was the lower socioeconomic rungs
they're the ones that haven't come back
and they're the ones that are holding up
you know the economy from moving again
and it's all caused by these extended uh
out-of-control government programs and
it's not being helpful they're trying to
be helpful but that's not helpful to
that person 10 years from today to teach
them to not work we'll get some more
with dave ramsey in just one moment
first let's talk about your sleep
quality so you got the great mattress
your room is the right temperature but
you're not sleeping well maybe it's
because you bought a set of sheets from
like that local store and it wasn't a
very nice set of sheets you haven't
thought about it here's the thing you
need a great set of sheets this is where
bull and branch comes in this cyber week
bowlin branch is offering their best
deal of the entire year and if last
night's sleep wasn't incredible their
sheets will make all the difference with
bowling branch you can get the best
sleep of your life with their highest
quality organic cotton sheets husband
and wife team scott missy tannen founded
bowlin branch to create a new standard
in betting by doing things the right way
not the easy way bowlin branch holds
themselves to high standards across the
board it's not just their sheets that
are made the right way they do pillows
and bath towels and robes as well their
signature hem sheets those are the
all-time bestseller we have a pair of
those they're just spectacular in fact
their sheets are so good we got rid of
all of our other sheets that's just how
comfortable they are this cyber week
gifts your loved ones the best sleep of
their lives or treat yourself with bowl
and branch their holiday packaging and
famously soft sheets blankets pillows
and more make a difference everyone will
feel get 25 off from november 23rd
through december 2nd with their best
offer of the year at bowlingbranch.com
that's 25 off at b-o-l-l and branch dot
com exclusions may apply we're speaking
with dave ramsey he has a brand new book
out called baby steps millionaires that
is well worth the read so dave a lot of
people have a bunch of money that the
government stuffed in their pocket over
the course of the last couple of years
while they were being told not to go to
work the government was just sending
them checks just helicopter and cash to
people and right now obviously we've
seen inflation eating away at those
savings and a lot of people think okay
i'm just leaving that money in the bank
to do nothing exactly where would you
recommend that people put their money
because right now it seems like people
are just throwing money at consumer
goods because they don't know what else
to do with the money we've seen people
investing in a wide variety of sort of
new investment types ranging from
cryptocurrencies to things like nfts now
where would you recommend that people
put that money if they've got money
lying around right now well anytime you
get desperate right after that
financially you get stupid
i've i've done it and you know if you
start getting desperate and you're
freaking out over these the spike in
inflation or you're freaking out all
over all these disturbances in the
economy and you go to some kind of
desperate move to get rich quick in some
unproven process uh that's just not wise
and so i can tell you what i'm
personally doing i'm personally
continuing to do what i've done for 30
years i buy mutual funds in long track
record mutual funds in my 401k and
outside the 401k and i buy real estate
that i pay cash for it's very simple
very boring nothing sexy about it i
don't get to tell my golfing buddies
some story that's that made me look
brilliant uh but you know it's resulted
in several hundred millions of dollars
of net worth so it's working out okay
so let's talk about your your actual
book the the baby steps in the book that
help people become a millionaire so what
are those steps well it's the baby steps
that we have taught for almost 30 years
in financial peace university and in our
other books and so if you've read other
dave ramsey books you're not going to be
shocked when you open this one up but
what we found out was that it was that
now that we've been doing this so long
there's tens of thousands of
millionaires that are millionaires
because they worked this plan that we
taught them 10 years ago 12 years ago 18
years ago and they're coming into our
office to do those debt-free screams
that we do on the radio and they're
saying oh by the way when i paid off my
house the other day it's worth 450 000
i've got a little over a million in my
401k so i'm worth a meet and half i'm a
baby steps millionaire and that's where
it comes from they follow the baby steps
baby step one through three is basically
get out of debt and build your emergency
fund this book is about four through six
and four is put fifteen percent of your
income
into retirement now the average
household income is 60 000. if you put
15 of 60 000 away from age 30 to age 65
you'll have between 5 and 10 million
dollars in your mutual funds and so if
i'm
10x 5x wrong
which i'm not you'd still be a
millionaire you know and and that's how
ridiculously simple this is now that's
not billionaire you're not going to have
seven lamborghinis in a private jet a
billionaire is a thousand
million
there's a lot of difference in elon or
uh you know some of the other guys out
there that we talk about the warren
buffets of the world there's a lot of
difference in those guys and a
millionaire a millionaires
living in a middle class house got two
cars got a nice ford pickup most of the
time so when do you think that it's
worthwhile to take risks so a lot of
your strategy is about making sure that
you don't take risks because a lot of
risks fail and if you're trying to just
build a nest egg of wealth and make sure
that you have wealth for the future and
for retirement a lot of that rests in in
making
smart predictable safe moves when do you
think that it's worthwhile to take a
risk and actually take a swing it's
about ratios uh i would take a swing
with an amount and the way i always
visualize it is if i put that amount of
money in the middle of my kitchen table
and set fire to it
meaning the risk goes poorly we lose the
whole thing
okay does it affect my life
is this a is this a major setback
uh and if the answer is no then you can
take a swing with that amount of money
and so if you want to invest in beanie
babies or bitcoin or
gold or you've got this itch to start a
business and you don't know what the
flip you're doing uh as long as you're
not betting the whole farm on it and
sliding all the chips forward like james
bond at the poker table going all in
you know that's the people that lose
everything
and uh and then they get the opportunity
to start again
and so don't do that but if you're going
to take a risk for instance i don't buy
single stocks and i don't recommend
single stocks but you can make a lot of
money in a single stock i always tell
people that are itching to do that put
no more than 10 percent of your net
worth in that so if you've got a 2
million net worth and you got 200 000 in
single stocks and they all go belly up
you're still okay you got a 1.8 million
dollar net worth you're going to be all
right you know you're okay everything's
fine but where everybody gets crazy is
when their whole thing
is based on a ridiculous high-risk
premise one of the things you talk about
in in the book is baby step number seven
which is about living and giving and and
being generous so
how does that make your life richer and
how does that make you better
financially well here's what's
interesting i mean we started the the
whole conversation with the idea this is
thanksgiving day we're grateful
uh is that people who are grateful
are generally generous
people who are generous or generally
grateful
and by the way those are two personal
character qualities that make you highly
attractive
everybody wants to be around you not
because they're trying to get money off
of you but generous people are just
generous they're generous in
conversation they're the ones that hold
the door for you they're not above
picking up the plate after dinner and
taking it to the dishwasher when you're
at someone's home you know
generous people are givers they're not
takers and we all know both kinds of
people
and here's what's interesting that's a
decision
you can just decide today i'm a generous
person it's not a gene you're not born
with it it's not a dna it's not an
amount of money
i'm just going to be a person who adds
value to situations
not takes value i'm not a parasite i'm
someone that adds value and so
generosity oddly enough changes the
person's appearance it changes the way
they carry themselves it changes the
octave you use when you're speaking it
changes so many things that are not
quite discernible but are right there to
where we all know who that guy is that
gal is that's generous and they tend to
move into tremendous opportunity in
their lives and they tend to prosper
more than the takers do the odd thing is
the taker the greedy person is trying to
prosper by climbing over people's bodies
and that's the very thing that holds
them back i found this is so true in in
my life and in business generally is
that the people who tend to think that
they are the most successful are the
people who think that they're the most
cut throat and that's not the way the
business really works if you make a deal
with somebody and you slit their throat
in the deal that is not a repeat
customer that is not somebody you can do
business with again if you make a deal
that is good for both sides you're going
to do business with that person over and
over and over again because everybody
has benefited from the deal this is
something that i think critics of free
markets just do not understand is that
capitalism is a repeat game it is a
repeat iteration game it is not like you
you have one deal in front of you and
whatever you get from this deal is what
you get from that deal it is a game
where you're gonna have to come back to
that same table and you're gonna have to
make a deal with the person next time
around and what we have found in all
studies of human psychology is that if
you screw that guy this time he is
absolutely gonna try to stick it to you
next time yeah and worse than that
they're going to tell everybody they
know
to stay away from you it's not just you
lose the one customer you lose their
entire tribe you lose everyone they have
influence with and so you know my friend
rabbi daniel lapin that you and i have
discussed several times uh you know he
says if you go to the auto repair shop
and the guy fixes your car and he walks
out and you go how much and he goes ah
it was it was a 25 cent part don't worry
about it just remember me you will
remember that guy
but if you go to the guy and he messes
you over
he's not in business in two years
because an auto repair guy who does a
great job
is a unicorn everybody's gonna send
somebody there you know that's a i'm
gonna tell all my friends i found one
you know i found a good one
and the opposite is true if he messes me
over and so this idea that somehow
capitalism without a moral component to
it
works is ridiculous it doesn't work
that's not how capitalism works
capitalism is an act of service
and when you serve someone well uh you
know they get
but another buddy of mine says ken
blanchard says that profit is the
applause your customers give you
you know and they say thank you they say
thank you ben shapiro i got to listen to
you you're one of the hottest things in
talk radio right now we're so proud of
you by the way you're an incredible
talent and i'm honored to call you a
friend but i mean this guy right here is
look what he's doing in america right
now he's moving the needle he's causing
a ruckus everywhere he goes and making
people think different and challenging
on an intellectual level instead of an
emotional level he's bringing value to
the marketplace and guess what
prospering out your ears and you should
first of all really appreciate the
praise and back at you on all of that
let's talk for a second about the
american dream because we've been told
by nearly every politician that the
american dream is dying or dead and it's
a it's a good political pitch because if
you tell everybody that their own
problems are not their fault it's the
fault of the system and that you are
capable of fixing all of the faults in
the system so long as you are given
power a lot of people have a tendency to
believe that it's a really attractive
notion that you never have to look
inward you never have to blame yourself
you never have to look at your own
decision-making process you just say it
was the system that screwed me over and
if i give this guy over here the power
to do what he says he can do he will
make my life better then of course we
find out five minutes later he can't
make it all better and then we get angry
at him and we throw him out for the
other guy and we just keep going around
in this cycle you know one of the points
that you're constantly making is that
not only is the american dream not dead
the american dream is more possible for
more people than it ever has been it's
thanksgiving let's talk a little bit
about that well this
wonderful digital world that we live in
i mean the way we're doing this
interview right now was not available
five years ago
and so i mean the money that someone can
make on a youtube channel the money they
can make with a podcast the money they
can make with a digital application of
content of any kind right now there's
all kinds of ways to deliver product out
of your garage that just simply wasn't
possible in an analog analog world and
so uh i mean the the opportunities are
infinite out there if your brain is
screwed in right now here's the thing
racism is real
it's a problem
sexism is real
all kinds of isms that are systemic are
real
and there are all kinds of jerks out
there that that do people wrong that are
immoral that don't function properly in
our culture today bring toxicity to
these discussions and it is systemic it
is systemic
but
it is the system you live in so you got
to decide am i going to ride the wave of
negative into victimhood and entitlement
or am i going to rise above whatever the
thing is that's coming at me
and uh you know i i'm have a southern
accent i'm in nashville tennessee and i
was told uh 30 years ago when we started
in radio that we would never succeed in
talk radio because no one's going to
listen to that hillbilly draw
and if you don't move to l.a or move to
new york and drop that accent you're
never going to have credibility because
everybody's going to think you you
broadcast from a double wide
but we got 638 radio stations sean
hannity's number one talk radio i'm
number two so apparently they were wrong
but i had to overcome that with a boston
affiliate i had to overcome that with a
new york city affiliate a miami
affiliate because
people speak northern and miami more
than they do southern these days but you
know and so on and so i had to actually
be intelligent in spite of my accent
hello so you got to rise above this
stuff and i talk about my friend condi
rice in the book as well and
she grew up in in a segregated
birmingham
alabama rough in those days it was
nicknamed bomingham it was bad
and uh
and you know
first black secretary of state female
right first black
president uh provost at sanford female
concert pianist uh just incredible
renaissance woman i mean her purse is
smarter than me it's ridiculous but the
things she's been able to accomplish
because her parents said it doesn't
matter where you come from
all that matters is where you're going
well the book is again baby steps
millionaires that steve ramsey should
give a listen to his show of course if
you if you haven't already it is
inspiring it is it is filled with wisdom
and so is the book david it's always a
pleasure to talk to you and have a
wonderful thanksgiving you too my friend
next time you're nashville hauler we'll
get together again sounds great
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed